[Musique]
Halloween fait toujours recette on va en
parler avec notre invité Yannick kirofr
bonsoir vous êtes le responsable
événementiel vie associative de la ville
de voisin le Bretonneux et je fais tout
de suite une correction j'aiévoqué le
centre Alfred devini ils ne vous ont pas
aidé hein sur le dispositif qui a été
mis en place à l'occasion d'Halloween
non non c'est bien une initiative de la
Ville qui a travaillé donc avec
plusieurs associations pour mettre en
place ces rendez-vous ce sera dans le
parc de la croix du bois voisin le
Bretonneux soirée Halloween alors
Halloween on va s'intéresser au revenant
à présent c'est une fête célébrée à la
veille de la toussin héritée des pays
anglo-saxons qui commémore la légende de
Jack à la lanterne condamné aéré
éternellement dans l'obscurité entre
l'enfer et le paradis en s'éclairant
d'un tison posé dans un navet le navet
devenu citrouille ça c'était pour
l'éclairage historique on comme ça on
sera un peu plus intelligent à la fin de
la journée Halloween qui a connu un fort
engouement ces dernières années mais il
y a eu un petit essoufflement là il y a
une vraie demande là vous organisez ce
rendez-vous avec beaucoup de demandes de
la part des familles ça s'adresse aux
enfants c'est c'est la deuxème édition
l'an dernier pour la première ça a
plutôt bien fonctionné on a eu quasiment
300 personnes des enfants qui étaient
ravis donc on réédite fort de ce succès
on espère avoir plus de monde c'est vrai
que là on a des affiches on a le service
de communication de la ville qui a fait
un beau travail on a beaucoup de coup de
fil il y a un certain engouement on en
est pas peu fier on a vous avez toujours
célébré halloween halloween vous euh oui
personnellement oui j'aime j'aime
beaucoup cette fête là j'aime beaucoup
me déguiser mes enfants adorent ça enfin
voilà donc on est très fr et là vous
prépareer l'organisation de ce
rendez-vous que vont découvrir les
visiteurs la croix du bois ce sera le
mercredi 31 octobre oui c'est bien donc
demain soir à partir de 19h les familles
vont pouvoir venir et euh venir voir
tous les décors qui ont été préparés par
l'association souja donc il nous fait
des décors magnifiques de la
scénographie il y a quand même pas mal
de choses à 20h30 il nous propose une
pièce de théâtre parceque en plein air
on jouera une pièce de théâre qui
s'appelle Harry pot fleur donc une
parodie bien sûr de du du petit sorcier
bien connu
il y aura les animateurs de la ville qui
montent pas mal d'ateliers dont un
couloir de la peur qui avait très bien
fonctionné l'année dernière il y a une
soupe de citrouille à déguster il y a un
stand maquillage et on a le photoc club
vcinois association donc photo qui nous
fait un studio et donc toutes les
familles et tous les enfants qui
viendront pourront être pris en photo et
les photos seront disponibles sur le
site internet de la ville à partir de
lundi c'est pour faire peur cette soirée
donc vous allez rassurer quand même les
ENF c'est pour s'amuser à se faire voilà
c'est c'est totalement gratuit c'est le
plaisir de s'amuser une fois par an à se
faire peur et tout est gratuit oui
totalement bien sûr bien sûr totalement
gratuit la soupe de citrouille les
bonbons qui sont offerts enfin tout tout
ce travail tout ce montage euh voilà
c'est offert et c'est pour vraiment
s'amuser on espère que qu'il y aura du
monde enfin voilà ça s'adresse
uniquement au Vinois ou pas ah non non
non tous les C50 chinois les affiches
sont sur la ville tous ceux qui
traversent peuvent venir l'année
dernière d'ailleurs les affiches avaient
bien fonctionné on avait des des gens de
de de partout HM le rendez-vous qui a
bien fonctionné on va peut-être voir des
des images justement de de l'édition
précédente pourquoi vous avez décidé
d'organiser ce rendez-vous c'était une
demande de la population ou c'est comme
ça de vous dire bon pourquoi pas on
tente et puis on voit si ça marche c'est
surtout parce qu'on a un parc qui est
magnifique le parc de la croix du bois
et euh ce ce parc là c'est euh se se
joue totalement à ça j'étais animateur à
l'époque il y a une dizaine d'années et
euh j'ai eu l'occasion de faire
Halloween là-bas il y a une on pourra le
voir sur les images il y a une maison
qui ressemble énormément à une maison
hantée les arbres sous certains
l'éclairage se prête totalement on est
vraiment dans cet univers Tim Burton est
un voisin bretonux demain quoi ça tombe
bien effectivement cette actualité par
rapport à justement à toute cette mise
en place vous avez commencé dès à
présent parce qu'on a vu des images de
l'an dernier il y a eu beaucoup de
travail de fait he sur la miseis depuis
ce matin euh les équipes de la ville
sont sur le le B de guerre ils sont en
train de travailler avec souja et donc
ont mis en
place pas mal d'éléments il beaucoup de
nouveaux éléments donc le on a étendu
les décors sur sur tout le parc euh et
puis et puis bah demain c'est le plus
gros avec le montage de du podium pour
accueillir une pièce de théâtre cette
pièce de théâtre je l'ai pas dit mais
c'est joué par des enfants écrit et joué
par des enfants c'est c'est un petit peu
nouveau voilà ça vaut vraiment le coup
elle est super drôle et donc pour ceux
qui sont venus l'an dernier c'est
l'occasion de revenir ce sera encore
plus grand encore plus important cette
soirée d'Halloween du côté de voisin
Bretonneux merci d'être venu sur le
plateau mercredi 31 octobre dans le parc
de la croix du bois à voisin le
Bretonneux vous pouvez déjà vous
renseignnez faut réserver ou pas ou non
on peut venir comme ça entré libre entré
libre merci beaucoup pour ce passage sur
le plateau et puis à noter également que
le parc de toirien célébra Halloween ce
mardi soir 30 octobre et puis demain
également mercredi 31 octobre les
animaux reçoivent déjà depuis plusieurs
jours leur repas dans des plats
originaux des citrouilles bien sûr mais
lors des soirées spéciales il faudra
aussi aller à la rencontre des sorcières
et des fantômes pour les enfants les
adultes devront enquêter sur les
créatures d'outre Tombre les détails
auprès du parc il y a de la con
concurrence autour de l'organisation
d'Halloween vous craignez pas la
concurrence non pas du tout et puis ça
s'adresse pas au même public et c'est
payant et c'est du côté de poiris alors
quein breton c'est gratuit voilà vous
êtes en plateau vous pouvez le dire le
78 revient demain mercredi d 18h en
direct avec de nouveaux invités vous
pourrez revoir cette émission cette
édition dè demain sur notre site
internet le matin et vous entendrez
notamment ce témoignage du doyen de la
Faculté de droit de l'Université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin en Yveline qui
se trouve à New York actuellement nous
étions en ligne avec elle au début de
cette émission il y a moins d'une heure
alors que l'ouragan S vient de frapper
la côte Est je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur sur TVfil à
l'écoute de nos programmes je vous
retrouve
[Musique]
demain